hey I'm some lake from remedy and I'm  here to talk about quantum break quantum  break is the fusion of a cinematic  action game and a top-of-the-line  live-action show the game is about  heroes the show is about villains in the  game you play chat choice in a desperate  fight to stop the fracture that  threatens to cause the end of time in  the show in the style of an edgy modern  TV series you follow the schemes and  power play inside mana the cooperation  that's Chuck's main enemy we are working  hard to bring you an entertainment  experience like no other quantum break  will be out in 2050 and very excited to  tell you that we'll be presenting  quantum breaks time  amplified action gameplay for the first  time ever in August at Gamescom here's a  sneak peek of what's to come later this  summer enjoy